good morning John it's Wednesday March
4th this is being filmed significantly
in advance because I wanted to do
something weird and I'm trying it out
this is called truth or fail truth or
fail is a new fun thing that I've
created I'm gonna tell you two facts and
you are going to tell me which one is
true or you will fail this is going to
guide you through a sequence of videos
and if you are correct all five times
you will receive a very special prize
and I'm not telling you what that
surprise is truth or fail question 1
John Green won his first writing award
when he was 8 or Helen Hunt is the
oldest Hank green song that you have
ever heard
[Applause]
[Music]
you